I'm not someone who restricts myself to
one thing ever
I've never been that person maybe I have
EDD but I want to be able to do
everything don't accept the box and then
go show them that you're different
I don't really classify my own try stuff
like because I doubt it I kind of like
just look at it as music I don't want to
like to put myself into one genre rise
and shine it's an espresso time good
morning belief nation it's evan my one
word is believe and i believe in you i
believe you have an amazing gift inside
to you that i want to see exploded onto
the world so let's start your day off
right together grab your coffee and sip
on today's message don't limit yourself
over to you priyanka chopra why was it
important to produce I'm a storyteller
and I I'm not someone who restricts
myself to one thing ever I've never been
that person maybe I have a TD but I want
to be able to do everything why can't we
do everything sure you know as an
especially women we are great at
multitasking so I want to produce I want
to have a business I'm gonna I'm
producing here I'm gonna produce in
India Hindi films regional films and I
want to be able to act in them maybe not
you know there's so many things that I
can do which I want to be able to
explore people want to put you in a box
they'll want to tell you what you can
and you can't do and you know what
that's okay you can't control them
but you don't have to put yourself in a
box you can't let their limited
perspective of what you can and cannot
do define the person that you are don't
accept the box and then go show them
that you're different the reminds of
Kanye West has got this great line where
it says don't put me in a box if you put
me in a box you puttin yourself in a box
you don't even realize that when they
box me in or try to verbally put me in
some type of box will put Donda in a box
that they're really showing their level
of ignorance they're putting themselves
in a box here's a guy who was put in the
box his entire career he was making
beats
and nobody thought it'd be a good beat
maker and then all of a sudden he was a
good beat maker he then wanted to get
into rapping and people told him don't
go into rap and you're great at making
beats you can't be a rapper you're not
gonna make that transition and then he
became a great rapper I don't know if
you guys know this but Kanye has won 21
Grammy Awards he's one of the most
successful Grammy Award winning artists
of all time of all time and then he
decided I'm not gonna rap I'm gonna go
into fashion I want to make shoes and
people say you crazy you can't go off
and make shoes and then he makes a deal
with Nike and then he makes a deal with
Adidas and he starts selling out all of
his shoes and so the limits that people
put on him he doesn't accept now there
may be a whole bunch of other things
about Kanye that you don't like some of
the things he says some of the way he
acts you may not agree with it that's
okay don't pull that from him but that
unwillingness to be boxed in that
unwillingness to accept other people's
limitations I think is really really
really important it's what you can be
inspired by it's why I made one of my
first top ten roles videos on Kanye
because I wanted to show people the good
side is like yes there's all this
negativity but there's also a lot of
positivity that people are not taking
away from it so I look at my own career
you know science was my worst subject
growing up I hated it I dropped it as
soon as possible I was never into
computers
I liked sports I liked a bunch of other
things and suddenly in university I had
this opportunity to join a biotech
startup and be one of the owners and
like okay I'm not gonna limit myself
just because I sucked at science and
computers growing up but doesn't mean
that I can't have success here and so
because I removed the limits on myself
we started to have success I started to
win in that business when I sold that
company when we got acquired I became a
venture capitalist I knew nothing about
venture capital knew nothing about
raising money I just had his curiosity
an intuition I wanted to learn more
about it and so we did instead of
raising half a million to 15 million for
companies that wanted to grow that
turned into me being a public speaker
and me having my website again not
skills that I had I was not part of the
debate team or public speaking team or
anything I had the worst skills go back
in my youtube channel
from nine years ago and look at my
videos and how poor the content was I
did not have a natural ability for
somebody here even
Frank was passing by too many of such a
natural ability to be in front of the
camera no I've just done 6000 videos but
I didn't accept the limitation I didn't
accept the box that I couldn't go off
and do it right and so moving from the
website to a YouTube channel then being
an author I didn't think I wanted to
write books I hated writing I wasn't a
fan of writing I didn't want to write
books I didn't think I needed to write
books to get my message out there I'm
much more of a visual learner so I'd
much rather create videos but these two
books they just felt more like a book
than it would a video and so I didn't
accept the Box anymore but I didn't
accept the box that I'm not a writer and
so I so often find people hold
themselves back because they've accepted
the box that other people put them in
they've accepted the box that they have
put themselves in but it's not a real
box like you can easily break through it
it's just paper writes this paper super
soft box so you can easily smash through
if you wanted to it reminds me of the
story of the elephant it's an elephant
that is tied up to a tree with a with a
little chain and when they're babies
they can't break free of the chain
because they're too small and so they've
learned that I have this chain on me and
so this tree is here I have the chain on
I can't go as they get older if they
keep the chain on even though the
elephant could rip the tree with the
roots right out they've accepted the
limitation of that chain and they just
stay still and they recognize that
they're in captivity and they can't pull
it out and so every major growth that
I've faced and my business has come from
me yanking free one of those changes by
me smash it through one of those boxes
you know Alex told me the other week
that he hates it when people ask him
what does Evan do because it's hard for
him to come up with an answer and I love
that I don't accept the box and you
shouldn't either
now have a special bonus clip for you
but before getting to it my question of
the day for you today is I'm curious
what is the box what is the label what
are the limitations that other people
are putting on you they say you can't do
it leaving the comments below
let's break free of them together I'm
really curious to hear from you thank
you guys so much for watching I believe
in you I hope we continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
I'll see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot of espresso and enjoy the
bonus
I work spray so give me
I want to be viewed with the Great's
period not just the R and B grades I
feel like I feel like that's kind of
where people people missed the mark with
me a little bit like our B is our B was
my introduction into this whole musical
crafting it's where it's where I came in
it but our B is one room in the mansion
that is music know what I mean and I'm
trying to explore the mansion you know I
don't I don't got to just sit in this
one room yeah I don't think people
should put me in this one room that's
that's the reason that you know I've
ventured over into the pop world
ventured over into dream world just
trying to try to get people to look at
me as music in general not just R&B
music not just pop music and dance music
but just music I think people were just
hearing the same stuff and you know
there's a point where like you know
progressive house or whatever you want
to call it like you know 128bpm like you
know a couple years ago that was the new
hot thing that was what everyone want to
hear you know they want to go and dance
really fast or whatever it is they want
to go to a party and now it's like you
know there's been so much of it Tiger
was now pub with a new genre I guess
maybe it was because just like there's
no trouble like there's no beaches and
like the summers were shortened no way
so maybe I was just like I was sitting
in my room dreaming about summer
dreaming about beaches and dreaming
that's right maybe that was the reason
why I started making that music I made
today do you like the label tropical
house is that appropriate er yeah I
guess I guess it makes sense cuz it's
like it's it's music that fits for the
summer but I don't really like I don't
really classify my own try stuff like
cuz I doubt it I kind of like just look
at it as music I don't want to like to
put myself into one genre as you shift
your attention to your future and to
what's next I want you to think about
this quote from Henry Ford
whether you think you can do it or you
think you cannot you were right those
words are more meaningful today than I
would have ever thought when I was
sitting where you are I had the same
worries about my future as you all have
but what I would like you to think about
is it for the vast majority of you the
limitations on what you can achieve are
to a very large degree self-imposed
whether it is an external voice telling
that you cannot achieve something or
it's that internal voice of fear and of
doubt that prevents you from pursuing
your passion these can often be more
limiting factors than the actual career
world itself raise your standard Apple
at the core its core values is that we
believe that people with passion and not
one drop of my self-worth depends on
your acceptance of me
I don't ever give up I'd have to be dead
or absolutely incapacitated hey believe
nation if you want to see my all-time
favorite top ten Rose a success I have a
very special secret video for you these
are the individual clips that I have
personally learned the most from and
applied to my life and my business check
the link in description for details